the crowds are back
sixteen thousand flocked to cheltenham
on saturday the first time they've been
here in person for more than a year and
a half buzzing buzzing he's got a
quarter of a mill coming in
i think double jab now yeah so you just
got to sort of
try and live as normally as possible
it's been a long wait 19 months to wait
for this so yeah
really excited any concerns at all
obviously about
um
personally no no
we're not really bothered really i think
everyone just wanted to get back to to
normal life's got to get back to normal
at some point like you can't live
hidden away forever i think it's always
in our back of a mind but i think we've
just got to kind of be
safe and just enjoy our lives really now
i think that's kind of where everyone's
up to
think back to march 2020 and the
controversial goal cup meeting which in
the end came to symbolize an inevitable
and looming lockdown
but as the stands fill up this weekend
cheltenham is battling a coveted case
rate nearly three times that of the
national average
which raises the question of just how
long this round of freedom will last
in town the christmas party menus are
ready and the bookings are flooding in
like all hospitality this bar can't
afford to lose another christmas
it would be devastating if we have to
shut again and um it will make me
question
where are we gonna go now if we're gonna
we've got everyone's got the vaccine and
we're still going to lockdown then what
is our future and how we're going to
proceed now with this virus because it's
not going anywhere
the chancellor rishi sunak says vaccines
mean lockdowns and significant economic
restrictions are not on the cards that
is welcome news for business and a
public who understandably do not want to
go through a winter like the last but
despite that govid numbers are rising
and there are many who believe a plan b
or further will be needed
i'm seeing history repeating itself
epidemiologist tim spector says now not
later is the time to act plan b should
have started a few weeks ago
there's no
point in waiting for hospitals to be
overrun which they will be in some
regions soon before you start with a
fairly modest plan b
when it comes to when or if we return to
restrictions here
all bets are off
damn whitehead sky news in german